wasn't it sort of annoying and I don't
mean this in a funny way to go on a
vacation with Harry Styles okay hey he's
a nice kid and everything but the level
of Fame that kid has it had to be fun in
one way but also very annoying to uh
ideally I didn't find it I didn't find
it annoying in any way because I just
think he's so special as a human that
actually you don't have any of those
feelings because no bit of him like
there is someone who wants to embrace
the world that they're living in to the
absolute best that he can and you never
ever feel like that when we went on this
one vacation I made this pact where I
said I am only gonna eat when you eat
right I'm going to work out when you
work out and I'm gonna eat when you eat
and I'm gonna eat what you eat and I
think it's gonna have a really positive
impact on me he was like okay I lasted
like 36 hours and I was like no I'm out
why did you lose that why did you lose
her because because once I've had a
drink I'm like should we get some fries
you know and I'm on holiday and I know
that I do well going away with Harry
Styles and everybody in the [__]
Resort is coming up and screaming his
name you know what I'm saying yeah but I
I think it's quite good for me
I think it's good I think any any time
you can have a little bit of humbling is
great so when somebody goes when someone
comes up and they'll this has happened
quite a few times and I genuinely I I I
I I just I'm like I get it I get it he
this is this is
this is arguably the most famous man on
the or you know desirable famous man on
the planet right now and so people come
up and they go oh my God can will you
take a photo can you take a photo of us
and I'll take the bag of course and then
yeah then they go they just go oh hi and
then they take the photo and I go you
look great and that's it and I think
it's very very good I think really I
think it's a positive thing in your life
thank you